hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren ich befinde mich gerade im Urlaub
mit ein paar Freunden und da haben wir
uns gedacht
wir spielen eine Runde
Taktik selber an die Beine und Stop dich
in den mülltrolle
[Musik]
kann ich Deutsch sprechen
bin ich eine animationsfigur nee wäre
nicht real
Mist bin ich unter 50 ja ich spreche
auch kein Deutsch das bedeutet ich
spreche amerikanisch wahrscheinlich
alles klar mache ich Sport professionell
Videos
[Musik]
in Deutschland
okay
ja habe ich auf Instagram
aber nach eurem ich weiß wer ich bin ich
eine Person des öffentlichen Lebens
ich
nicht ganz
Alter
bin ich unter 30
bin ich unter 50
[Musik]
vorgestellt jeder sollte das eigentlich
auch kennen es ist ganz normales Wasser
was hier reingefüllt wird egal ob mit
oder ohne Kohlensäure und dann gibt's
verschiedene duften aufmachen kann es
gibt ganz crazy Geschmäcker wie
beispielsweise hier in dem Fall Mango
Maracuja es gibt auch Pfirsich es gibt
Cola es gibt Apfel wie viel Prozent wir
vom Geschmack über die Nase schmecken
Nase und das macht sich eher halt zu
Nutze weil wenn du trinkst und saugst
und das Ding hier
wenn man saugt
man sieht auf jeden Fall dran und
dadurch denkt das Gehirn dass man gerade
irgendwie in dem Fall irgendwas trinkt
tut man aber nicht und das ist halt ganz
cool für Leute die glaube ich zu wenig
Wasser trinken und generell ein Problem
damit haben Wasser ist ja eigentlich
geschmackslos daran irgendwie Interesse
zu haben das zu konsumieren deswegen
probieren sie wollte schon immer mal
probieren und jetzt im Video
durch die Nase krank danke auf jeden
Fall das heutige Videos mit dem Code
Laserdrucker hättet ihr noch 10% bis zum
30 Juni also schaut auf jeden Fall
vorbei alles ist unten in der
Videobeschreibung verlinkt und
Piraten jetzt weiter bin ich auch Social
Media ich würde sagen ja gibt's aber
ja selber nein
nee nee komme ich aus Deutschland 60
bin ich im Sportbusiness gar keine
Ahnung Alter bin ich in der Musikbranche
bin ich lustig
bin ich Comedian sich gut aus
[Musik]
dem Fernsehen mache ich Comedy
ja
bin ich
Politiker
sind 387 Stunden später
würde ich sagen Tobi jetzt den Tipp dass
du auf RTL läuft primär und Nelly kriegt
den Tipp dass sie auch etwas mit Essen
zu tun hat RTL das ist jetzt richtig
easy verloren
Reality-Formate
[Musik]
eben einen krassen Tipp geben ja
du hast du Musik zu tun du hast mir
Religion zu tun und du hast du
McDonald's zu tun was McDonald's
Kegeln welche Sendung auf RTL kennst du
die mit
[Musik]
Musik
McDonald's
[Musik]
keine Ahnung McDonald's
langweilig und irgendwie sehr langwierig
jetzt
boah
Alter
wenn es euch gefallen hat dann lasst
gern einen Daumen hoch unter dem Video
da abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt auf
die Glocken er ab sehr lecker danke noch
mal das heutige Videos ihr findet alle
Infos dazu in der Beschreibung ich
wünsche euch äh wunderschönes Wochenende
wunderschön ciao